what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot is going down over at Marvel
Studios right now we'll do a full video
breaking down everything that's
happening soon and what exactly it means
for the future of Marvel Studios and of
course the future of the MCU but today
we're going to be talking about Jonathan
Majors R king Jonathan Majors is a big
name right now he's been in a lot of
really big movies of course he appeared
as he who remains in Loki of course he's
Kang and Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and he was in the latest
Creed movie and unfortunately and sadly
he was arrested now many of you have
probably heard this news but we are
going to be diving a lot deeper into it
today than just his arrest apparently
since he was arrested a lot of
allegations have come out about him and
will try to reserve judgment until
everything comes to the service and
everything has context behind it but
like I mentioned since he was arrested a
lot of people have come out on Twitter
and have pointed out some things about
Jonathan Majors that aren't so good in
fact they're pretty bad however like I
said we'll Reserve judgment because a
rep for him told reporters that he did
nothing wrong and they look forward to
clearing this mess all up so what
happened was yesterday Jonathan Majors
was arrested Saturday morning for
allegedly assaulting a woman near
Chelsea in New York City he was arrested
on the charges of strangulation assault
and harassment however Jonathan majors
does say that he is innocent and he
denies that he is guilty of these
charges now TMZ has been reporting about
this claiming that they have details
however one of Jonathan Major's
Representatives told TMZ that I quote
he's done nothing wrong we look forward
to clearing his name and clearing this
up end quote but TMZ apparently spoke
with the NYPD and this is what they say
TMZ sources and law enforcement tell the
outlet that majors and his girlfriend
seemingly the alleged victim were in a
taxi Friday night when they began
arguing majors girlfriend allegedly
confronted the actor about him seeming
to text another woman and wanted to look
at his phone TMZ reports that this
angered Majors causing him to allegedly
snatch her hand and slap her according
to TMZ the woman had visible signs of
the alleged assault across her body she
is currently in stable condition at a
local hospital the police were contacted
around 11 A.M Saturday and the woman
told them that she and Majors had an
altercation which led the actor to
physically attack her according to TMZ
given the visible cut behind the woman's
ear and other redness invisible markings
on her face the police put majors in
handcuffs and brought him to jail
however he seems to be out of custody
currently the NYPD told the rap that the
arrest of Jonathan Majors was in
response to a domestic dispute and
Jonathan Majors went into custody
without incident meaning he didn't put
up a fight he didn't make a scene he
didn't resist arrest he just simply went
with them now again it's really hard to
tell what actually happened especially
when it's coming from TMZ TMZ really
does love the celebrity drama they tend
to exaggerate a lot as well so it is
really hard to know what actually is
going on here especially because his
Representatives say that they look
forward to clearing his name soon so
we're unclear of what happened but the
incident has already had Ripple effects
and here's where things get really
interesting and kind of sad for starters
Jonathan Majors was in a U.S army
campaign he was in an advertisement for
them but the US Army has recently since
learning about his arrest pulled the ad
whereas they said put it on pause Laura
D Francisco spokesperson for the Army
Enterprise marketing office said this
the US Army is aware of the arrest of
Jonathan majors and we are deeply
concerned by the allegations surrounding
his arrest while Mr Majors is innocent
until proven guilty Prudence dictates
that we pull our ads until the
investigation into these allegations is
complete so that's one effect the ads
that he was doing for the US Army me
have been pulled but now even more
serious ones are coming to light
Jonathan Majors is now being accused of
abusive and vicious behavior and this is
even coming from a director and some
people that he was around in his college
Years and these allegations if they are
true are concerning filmmaker a B Allen
back in February said this in a tweet
there's a particular actor relatively
new on the scene who Twitter has
violently Fallen head over heels for who
in actuality is a vicious cruel abusive
human being both professionally and in
his personal life and every new viral
thirst tweet about him drives me insane
and now some users are tweeting now we
know who this tweet is about in response
to Jonathan Majors getting arrested in
which Abe Allen replied with ding ding
ding confirming his tweet was indeed
about Jonathan Majors now since this all
came out AB Allen was kind of pressed
about why he isn't releasing more
information about him now and he stated
the specifics of what I know
unfortunately would still expose people
who have been hurt and deserved to not
become part of some larger media inquiry
if they don't want to so I'm not gonna
get into the details but now you all
know what his deal is so so he confirms
that is Jonathan Majors that he was
talking about but he's not going to say
more because there are other people
involved and he doesn't want them to be
brought into the spotlight because he
doesn't want them to have to deal with
it which is understandable and
unfortunately it doesn't stop there with
this tweet Society theater co-founder
and Broadway actor director Tim Nikolai
also came out and tweeted and it is
worth noting that the Tweet has now been
made private but of course it's the
internet and everybody snapshot it and
we have the tweet and he came out and he
said this I'm just gonna say this about
Jonathan majors and be done with it
Folks at Yale and the broader NYC
Community have known about him for years
he's a sociopath and abuser and that is
how virtually everyone speaks about him
it's a shame it took this long for him
to be reported and the same thing kind
of happened with him that happened about
the other tweets people were asking him
why haven't you come out with this
before and he responded by saying this
I'm already seeing a bunch of why didn't
you do anything folks people have tried
ultimately needed a victim to come
forward it's both simultaneously awful
to know he is still doing this and also
a relief that he may never get to do it
again and Tim Nikolai said the same
thing that A B Allen said stating a
bunch of us are close with people and
sometimes multiple people he has
directly harmed I don't know if they
will speak on it it's completely their
decision basically saying what a B Allen
said they don't want to talk more about
it because they don't want to bring
these other people into the spotlight
now of course right now there's not
really a way of confirming anything and
we don't know the details Behind these
reports so we really can't say anything
about them until we kind of get an
official response from Jonathan Majors
or a spokesperson for him but an enough
people seem to be coming out and
complaining about him that it is indeed
going to be causing a problem definitely
for him but also for Marvel Studios Kang
is the next big bad we are literally
about to go into the Kang Dynasty and
then in secret Wars where we're going to
meet a lot of Kings which in turn are a
lot of Jonathan Majors there are
definitely some allegations against him
right now but in Show Business many
actors have claimed to be hard to work
with until we really know the details
about what actually happened with these
people it's hard to really say what
Marvel Studios is going to do and the
spokesperson for Jonathan major seems to
be pretty confident that his arrest and
the allegations for his arrest are not
what they seem and that they can easily
find a way to prove that he was innocent
in this situation and did not abuse his
girlfriend so although these are serious
claims it's kind of a waiting game right
now to see what really comes to light
and I think Marvel Studios is most
likely going to be waiting on that as
well before they make any type of move
but for those who have been asking me on
Twitter and on Instagram I don't
personally Force see them doing anything
right now if some bad allegations come
out and get proven then they might have
to take action but then again we know
that Ezra Miller is still working with
Warner Brothers and Amber Heard is still
in the next Aquaman movie so you really
never know so again right now it's just
a waiting game to see what really comes
to light but go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below this definitely does come as
a bummer as I really love him as he who
remains and Kang the Conqueror I think
he did a great job so I'm hoping that
these are false claims or perhaps maybe
misunderstandings but we'll have to wait
and see so don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of this news and of
course news about the MCU and the new DC
Universe as well and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign